oprah winfrey is north america's first
black billionaire and is considered by
many to be the most influential woman
in the world she went from being born
into poverty in rural mississippi to a
teenage single mother to now being worth
2.6
billion dollars
need motivation what's your top 10 with
believe nation
top 10.
hey it's evan carl michael and i make
these videos because you are probably
the most
ambitious person that you know but you
also know that you're capable of more
and you get that push by surrounding
yourself with the best
so today let's learn from one of the
best oprah winfrey and my take on her
top 10 rules of success
enjoy okay let's kick it off with rule
number one be the master of your own
faith
there's a bigger dream waiting for you
just waiting for you to step into it
to step into it your life is big
your life is huge and we spend so much
time
wanting to be in somebody else's life
and you don't get honored you don't get
revered
you don't get celebrating wanting what
somebody else has
because that which created you divine
intelligence that dreamed you from
before
your ancestors ever knew they would
become
your ancestors that which dream the seed
of you wants you to know
how special how wondrous how mysterious
how complex how glorious how phenomenal
you are and you get no credit
messing in somebody else's territory
or trying to have power
over something you have no control
another one of my favorite teachings
is the wizard of oz when the wicked
which is the west says go away from here
because you don't have any power here
you have no power in any territory other
than
your own oh but you
are the master of that you get to be the
master of your own fate you get to be
the captain of your
own soul and if you just manage that
if you just took care of your territory
all the glorious glorious glorious
wondrous wondrous opportunities
and possibilities that are waiting for
you so the question is what
are you resisting what are you
pushing against what are you not
allowing
what are you blocking because you have
this
idea of who and what you're supposed to
be
instead of leaning into the dream
that's already been created and waiting
for you it's waiting for you and the
second
i mean it doesn't it's an instant thing
it's a shift
in the way you see yourself and the
power from which you have come
rule number two stay in the light and
this is the thing
i think i have to just say listen
everybody is feeding yourself
on the hysteria and the negativity
you gotta stay in the light but one of
the reasons why i was so excited
is about a wrinkle in time because the
message is
that the darkness is spreading so fast
these days
you must become a warrior of the light
and the reason that's so meaningful to
me
is because that's how i've led my whole
life and
every moment in that film i just felt
like i'm just saying what i've
normally said it's true and and for
these
times the darkness is there to show you
your light
look at what has happened so if you put
the focus on
look at what happened with the darkness
that showed up in parkland
and the darkness that showed up on the
streets of ferguson and the darkness
that showed up
in many many many many many many homes
in chicago with shootings and
uh senseless murders it brings out the
best
in people it brings out the best and so
that's what it's there
we live on a planet where there is
darkness
and light rule number three cultivate a
spiritual life
i teach them that there is no life
without
cultivating a spiritual life because you
are
first and foremost a spiritual being
having a human experience and if you
lose sight of that
it's easy to get lost in the world and
no one can save a world that they're
lost in
when they've lost sight of their own
north star
so having a spiritual life actually
means actively
and ritually creating the space in your
life
all the time for gratitude for kindness
for empathy for inspiration for joy
and for reverence for life in the home
of your soul first and then working to
spread
that inner joy outward it means slowing
down
it means taking in the moment it means
being exactly
where you are not distracted
somewhere else it means knowing who you
are
and getting about the business of
fulfilling
why you really came to our planet
rule number four trust your instincts i
started
feeling like i think everybody knows
i i've moved my whole life on instinct
you know i
feel like now it's time to let the show
go i feel like it's time
to move on because i've grown as much as
i can grow
when i've grown as much as i can grow in
a space that's my instinct to move
also if you want to have unstoppable
confidence and self-love
check out my 254 series they're free the
links to join on the description below
figure out where your power base is
your number one job is to become more of
yourself
and to grow yourself into the best of
yourself
become so skilled so vigilant
so flat out fantastic
at what you do that your talent can
not be dismissed rule number five
push through difficult times i went
through some tough times
after after i left the oprah show i made
a conscious decision
that i did not want to be sitting on tv
with the oprah show and y'all saying she
should have left that show
that show was really good two years ago
i made a conscious decision decision
that when i felt i had said
all that i could say and the audience
had heard it that i would move on
and that i would not spend my life
regretting or trying to hold on to what
used to be or hold on to what i had
so i dreamed this dream of starting a
network
and in the beginning it was it was a
struggle
it was a struggle because i didn't
honestly the goodness i did not know
what i was doing
i was trying to figure it out i was
trying to figure it out
i thought that the oprah show audience
would follow us to own
then i realized y'all didn't have cable
and if you had cable you did not have
the own package
[Applause]
so so it took me a minute and
unlike most people who you get to have
your mistakes in private
some don't go right in your life you get
to soak about it in private
if i make a mistake it's on the cnn
crawl
or the cnn news so when i was in the
climb and there were so many wonderful
owners i see churro action jackson here
there were so many wonderful owners
people who said oh we're going to stand
with you we're going to stand by you
thank you roland martin
there were so many people who said
listen we believe that this can happen
so i dreamed the dream along with tyler
perry who was my friend who came to me
and said tyler
[Applause]
tyler said i'm going to help you out
because tyler can go home and write a
script and
direct it produce it and shoot it
and do it for less money than anybody in
hollywood so we started with the
foundation
of having have not
if loving you is wrong
love thy neighbor mama hattie
and then i started to dream another
dream about
scripted television because in the
beginning i was told you couldn't do it
you couldn't do it didn't have enough
money to do it
and i dreamed the dream
i read proverbs 11 28 that says those
who trust in their riches will fall
but the righteous will rise and thrive
like a green leaf rule number six become
the best version of yourself
it is your job to make yourself whole
not perfect but whole and full
your world work in life your real work
is to fill yourself to your cup
runneth over so that you're never
grasping
and needy clamoring and insecure
but you can live your life assured in
your worthiness
and your right to be here and to become
the best
version of yourself as a woman being
rule number seven
don't be ashamed of your past you came
from very modest circumstances you
didn't come from a wealthy family well
modest is not the word
well i was trying to be polite i was i
was actually
poor and i you know a lot of the girls
at my school
actually all the girls from my school
are poor and i was saying to them just
recently i was just in south africa for
graduation
you know you all are comf come from the
same circumstances you were poor
and one of the girls raised their hand
and said i don't like using that word
i go well if you're not poor then you
should excuse yourself because
that's why i'm paying for you because
you're in my school so if you're not but
you don't like the choice of the word
so i don't i don't have a problem with
the word i don't have any shame about it
i think
you know probably earlier in my life or
career
the word would have bothered me but it
truly it was it was i was poor
no running water david or electricity
living with an outhouse okay that's poor
rule number eight establish meaningful
connections
you can't get what you want by focusing
on what you don't want
this is about the need to establish
as many meaningful connections as we can
if we're going to save the world we have
to find a way
to connect to each other to connect to
the nature that
we're killing to animals to history to
an acknowledgement
of the lingering trauma of racism and
sexism
we need to connect to the people we love
and mean
something to us and more than that to
the people who don't
that doesn't mean we always have to
agree with another person's philosophy
it means we if we're going to continue
to survive and thrive on this planet
have to find ways to transcend
the politics of division and embrace the
places that
bond us where we find our human ground
rule number nine surrender to the dream
everybody works hard
and everybody has their own dreams there
is
there was a time where i used to spend a
lot of energy wanting things
wanting things of course it's easy for
me to say oh things don't define you
because i got a lot of things things are
nice i like them
but this is what i learned when you can
surrender to the dream
you get to live in the space of the
higher power
you get to live in the space that you
purposefully have come to earth to claim
for yourself
so around 1984
i was sitting in bed one morning sunday
morning should have been in church but i
wouldn't
i was reading the new york times review
of the color purple and i thought whoa
this sounds like a really great book i
got out of bed in my pajamas
put on my galoshes and went to the store
to get the copy of the color purple
i read the color purple in one afternoon
got went back to the bookstore bought
every book of the color purple
i took the books to to the office and i
said to everybody y'all got to read this
book oh my god you got to read this book
color purple i needed a book club i
didn't have one
so i passed out the book to everybody i
knew please read the color purple read
the color
purple then i start to hear that
somebody's going to do a movie about the
color purple but i don't know anybody in
the movie business
by this time i was on am chicago i don't
know anybody i start praying to god
god please help me find a way to get
into color purple
i say jesus i don't even have to have a
speaking part
i will be because i went to the movies
and i saw on the movie credits
at the last credit there's something
called best boy
so i said jesus if you just let me be
best girl
that'd be all right by me i can be best
girl
i can carry the script i can help the
people with the water i can do whatever
so i start praying for the color purple
as as divine law would have it
quincy jones comes to chicago and
he is in chicago for one half of a day
because somebody has filed a suit
against michael jackson
claiming that billie jean was their
lover and that's not his song
so quincy had taken the red eye to
chicago
he was in his hotel room he was coming
out of the shower and the television
in his hotel room is on am chicago
there sits little chubby me
with my jerry curl
on am chicago quincy jones tells ruben
cannon the casting agent
i think i found sophia so i get a call
from ruben cannon who says i'm calling
about a movie
it's called moon song would you be
interested to come and audition
and i say i have not been praying for
moon song
i had not been playing for moon song
i've been praying for the color purple
he said well i think you should come and
and audition so i go to audition
you know movie people they make
everything all secret stephen spielberg
didn't want anybody know he was doing
color purple so
on the outside of the script it says
moon song but i know
all the words by heart
so when i open the script i know this is
the color purple jesus
this is the color purple
yes
so i auditioned for the color purple i
can't even believe it they don't just
want me to be the water girl
or the best girl they are asking me do i
want a part
in the movie oh that i'm thinking prayer
prayer works
[Music]
prayer works but listen to this
three months pass three months is a long
time
i auditioned in february march april
may comes i haven't heard anything so i
call reuben cannon
i say mr cannon i'm sorry sir i haven't
heard anything
i expected to hear something by now and
reuben cannon
african-american man says to me
you don't call me
i call you and i didn't call you
do you understand that i have real
actresses who have auditioned for this
part
real actresses and he tells me who just
left his office and i went well okay i'm
not getting that part
so i hang up the phone and i start
crying
i can't believe that god has played this
trick on me i think
this is a trick so i decide that this is
because the fat
has finally caught up with me
the fat has finally caught up with me
and now i must get rid of the fat
in two weeks
i am going to go to a fat farm
and i'm going to lose 25 pounds
i'm gonna drink a lot of green juice
i'm gonna have some cleanses and
colonics
so i i also was trying to make
peace with it i said god
i don't understand i thought it was for
me you ever had that talk with god
i i thought it was for me i thought it
was for me
god you let me audition with somebody
named harpo
that's my name backwards jesus that was
a sign wasn't it a sign
and then three months pass and then then
reuben cannon says
real actresses have just left his office
so i start to pray on the track i'm out
on the track
at the fat farm
and i am running around at the track
at the fat farm it starts to rain
y'all know how that is
but i don't even care cause i am praying
to god
to help me to let it go
help me let it go because now i've
become obsessed with it and it's now
controlling my life
i start praying running around the track
and i keep hearing this noise and i
i can't there's nobody on the track but
me and i'm running around the track
and i look around and it is my thighs
rubbing together
it's my thighs
my thighs are rubbing together
causing this thunderous sound
there's nobody on the truck so then i
really start to cry
oh lord help me help me let it go
help me let it go help me let it go god
help me let it go and you ever did this
prayer where you say okay lord i'll come
and let it go then you get up and you go
well i think i still got a little bit of
it
i did help me let it go but i am not
going to be able to see the other
actress
in my part i won't be able to see it i
won't be able to see color purple
just can never see it the rest of my
life i won't be able to see it
so then i started i don't know where it
came from
i surrender all
i surrender all
all to thee my
blessed savior
i surrender all
i sang and i cried i sang and i cried
and i prayed some more
until i could reach the point where not
only
not only will i be able to go to the
movie but i can bless
the other actress i can bless her
i can say i bless you
i bless you i bless you with this i
surrender all i
surrender all
all to thee my
blessed savior
i surrender
all and i tell you
in my greatest testimony
that the instant i laid that thing down
[Music]
i'm telling you when i laid it down
when i laid it down and it didn't have
me
anymore it had no control over me
anymore
i didn't feel anything about it anymore
when i let it go
when i intentionally surrendered it to
the power
that was greater than i could ever know
the instant that happened a woman
comes running out of the cafeteria
screaming offering
is your name all free
for 10 years nobody can pronounce my
name
i said yes she said somebody's on the
telephone for you he's a named spielberg
i get to the phone
he says i hear you're at a fat farm
i said no sir
[Music]
this is a health retreat
[Music]
he says i'd like to see you in my office
in california tomorrow this was in
wisconsin i was i'd like to see you in
my office
and if you lose a pound you could lose
this part
no problem do i have
i'll have no problem not losing a pound
so honey i packed my bags
and i stopped at the dairy queen
[Applause]
i got three scoops just in case i'd lost
a half a pound
and the next day i was in steven
spielberg's office and he said
you're hired you're hired and rule
number 10 the last one before our very
special bonus clip
is have fun oprah i'm dying to know
what is in your purse
[Music]
i'm not quite sure myself okay
so somebody's gonna bring out my purse
[Applause]
[Music]
this is this is kelly herlin who dresses
me every day so this is
this this is uh
[Applause]
who did who did a real good job today
except i said to her i think these boots
are size
nine and i wear a size 10. they look so
cool though but i look cute but damn my
feet hurt
okay okay hey no no kelly just stand
here i don't know
this is the bag i was carrying this
morning it was right where'd you find
this
oh boy upstairs in the closet on the
table on the table
okay this is what's in my purse right
now
um okay so there's my little makeup bag
okay that's cute all in one bag
this was given to me by nate burkett uh
then there's
that then there's my there's my wallet
there's my um
blackberry the color purple uh y'all
should go see that i saw that
[Applause]
now these are the sunglasses ellen i
carry black pear and a brown pair
because you never know what you're going
to be wearing
this is a contact lens cleaning fluid
this is uh
uh charger for my blackberry
uh this is a movie freedom land
this is a uh oh this is great this is a
poem maya angelou just just gonna do the
white house
and uh okay what is this
oh this is uh this is uh this is my
angel's itinerary so i know where she is
and uh that's about it okay what i would
like to know is i got some pins down
here
and some glasses reading glasses and i
got
um sophie's balls just whenever we're
playing
she only likes the clear ones and uh
that's it
okay let's see how much money do i have
my wallet
okay i got receipts i keep those for you
when i was shopping the other day
then again this is how much my i got
pull out all my money here we go
yeah i have a wallet i have south
african rans
ran and hold on
two dollars
it's bad wait a minute oh oh no there's
more there's more money okay there's
more
there's more money there's 10 11 12 13.
14. now i've got a special bonus gift
from oprah on how to learn from your
mistakes that i think you're going to
enjoy but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know
what are your instincts telling you that
you need to trust
let me know what they are put them down
in the comments below and if you made it
this far in a video you're still here
watching
give me a hashtag believe down the
comments below
i want to celebrate you we don't just
watch videos here
we do something about it so give me that
believe in the comments below too
when did you realize in chicago or
baltimore that you actually had a skill
as an interviewer that was really better
than anybody else's
and where do you think that skill came
from i never thought it was better than
anybody else's what i do think i have
that is really uniquely my own is my
ability to connect to the audience
because my skill comes not from my
interviewing ability
my skill comes from my listening ability
and my skill comes from
me knowing fundamentally
inside myself that i am no different
than the audience
so what gave me the power in the seat
and the power with the microphone was i
always saw myself
as the surrogate for the audience so i
would ask people questions
that i would not normally ask i mean i
asked some really embarrassing ques
embarrassing question ones not because i
wanted to know the answer
but because i thought the audience did
and then i thought i'm not going to ask
what dolly just wants
the next time and when i get in that
situation it was it was a i put myself
in a bad stitch i asked
sally phil when she was dating bert
reynolds
i asked remember this gail i asked sally
field
did bert sleep with his toupee on
what was the answer or the question
and i would never do that today i
wouldn't do it
because i was doing it because i was
getting pushed by the producers like
people want to know
people want to know so i was thinking i
was doing it on behalf of the audience
she shut down and i could see that
it embarrassed her and i never got
another thing from her
so i thought okay that was wrong i
learned from that
[Music]
hey if you want more top 10 rules videos
they are no longer on this channel i
have a dedicated brand new channel just
for them
if you want to check it out go subscribe
the link is right there next to me
lots of great content go there go check
it out and continue to believe
and i'll see you there